the cancer is still spreading I'm afraid
there's nothing else we can do there is
one person who might be able to help our
program is a two-pronged treatment
outside Mexico City the results have
been stunning she saved my life
[Music]
you're in very good hands with us
after that what happens then your whole
life
John Kramer
according to these scans
the tumor was never removed how much
time do I have
months at best I still have a lot of
work that needs to be done
[Music]
thank you
hello everyone it's time to play a game
you all pretended to kill me the one I
have planned for each of you is very
real
peace
the only thing I have not provide is
your anesthetic but trust me
you will want to remain alert
[Music]
out of all the men to cheat you picked
John Kramer please don't hesitate
place a big enough piece of your
cerebral tissue into the glass enzyme
tank this will save your life
this is not retribution it's a
Reawakening
[Music]
live or die the choice is yours
foreign